here
we
go
back at it live once again let's go
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
CEO favorite podcast
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back
on today's episode NFL playoffs once
again
I lost my wallet well I thought I did I
got to tell you what happened
I saw this great Nick Cage movie on the
airplane I gotta tell you about that and
my new show my new jam Wayfair wishes on
AMC Plus
Let's Just Thoughts ideas just me being
me once again
welcome back
[Music]
different
yes riffing with Griffin back again live
in full effect so welcome to Griffith
with Griffin you can find me at Eric
griffin.com make sure you subscribe you
got to do that make sure you subscribe
like you know do all that stuff that you
do
uh you know if you want to be and if you
want to support the show
uh you could do it in many different
ways I'm on Twitch every single day most
like most days Eric Griffin gaming I'm
on fire on Call of Duty so you got to
check me out on that and you can be a
subscriber there if you want to support
your show monetarily you could do it
also on patreon which I have bonus uh
material coming out on that you know
weekly now
um I haven't started because the new
year but I'm I'm coming I got one coming
because I'm just gonna just you know do
what I do my random thoughts and ideas
and so you could also be a YouTube
member patreon member you can check me
out on all that stuff and if you want to
see me live guess what y'all if you want
to come see Daddy live
you could see me this week in Nebraska
at the district table in Norfolk
Nebraska I got three shows Friday and
Saturday January 20th and 21st if you go
to Eventbrite and you put in Eric
Griffin you can find it or District
table they don't necessarily have the
link on their website but you can go to
the district what is it
um yeah you can find a district table in
Norfolk Nebraska so Nebraska I'm coming
your way this weekend so let's do that
[Music]
all right and guys I got a new sponsor
of this show we got this great new
sponsor of the show called diet smoke
diet smoke makes federally legal premium
THC products delivered right to your
door for riffin with Griffin listeners
shop now at dietsmoke.com and use code
Griffin all right dietmoke.com use code
Griffin y'all so come check me out there
you know
it's actually not yeah yeah
dietsmoke.com
use code Griffin all right yeah I just
change that on the Fly
anyways uh so uh all the business is
taken care of thanks to everybody who's
live
um what's up everybody in the chat if
you ever want to watch me live I do it
sometime on Tuesday sometimes it varies
on a time I I probably should get like a
more specific time but come check me out
uh live and Janine thank you for the
super chat
um
anyways so you can check me out live on
Tuesdays but if you're listening on odd
on any on the audio platform I
appreciate you got your guys for your
support listening to riffing with
Griffin and for you if you're a newcomer
and this is your first time even being
listening to me at all you're like who's
that guy I think I know him from
Workaholics or wherever you know me from
and this is for new people for the new
people hey you might be like is this a
comedy podcast it is sometimes I'm funny
a lot of times I'm serious but I'm
authentically me all the time so this is
the the less silly side the silly stuff
you want to watch you can check me out
on the golden hour or gen to gen with
Matthew Espinosa so I got two other
podcasts but this one is just me my my
train of thoughts and for the people
that have been here all the time thank
you you all know what it's about and I
appreciate y'all being here once again
Griffin with Griffin singer Mike was
good today huh
the woo-woos I thank you for your
woo-woos um when you hit me up on the
golden Hour podcast I love all the
woo-woos so thanks for being here
um
what's going on and you know once again
check me out in if all those people from
Nebraska I'm taking over Adam Devine's
home state I'm coming to Nebraska taking
it over because of Adam's from Nebraska
yeah but then like I think Johnny
Carson's also from Nebraska so that that
just takes away all my thunder
but
why am i coughing already anyways
all right so I got to tell you something
that happened to me
um this past weekend and shout out to
Greensboro North Carolina everybody out
there came out to the shows the Saturday
night was pretty packed two good shows
but you know there was a lot going on
this weekend so I appreciate everybody
that came out to Greensboro North
Carolina never been there before uh
really it was it was so many interesting
types of people at the show because when
you go to some place like North Carolina
you think the South whatever but there
were so many different types of people
there it was great one I did was this
great lesbian couple like older ladies
you know and you can tell they've been
together for a long time and they they
adopted these two latino kids from I
forgot where they were from and they
were in the front row and it was just
and I was just like oh this is cool so a
lot of cool stuff uh in North Carolina
but this is what happened to me all
right
this is what happened so I
I thought I lost my wallet all right so
it was cold it's cold in North Carolina
but it wasn't as cold as I thought it
was going to be so the last night on
Sunday I'm leaving in the morning on a
10 a.m flight okay so I had this big
winter coat that I bought in Detroit but
it wasn't that cold so I had like a
jacket on and then I had the winter coat
over it but the jacket I was gonna wear
on stage you know with a t-shirt I like
how it looked so I had this winter coat
jacket so when I got there I got in the
green room I take the jacket off I leave
it on the chair I go up I do my show and
when I come out you know I'm talking to
the owner he's hands me my check I put
the check in my wallet right put the
check in my wallet and then I go blank
as I'm talking about for memory wise I
don't remember what happened after that
other than
I thought I put my wallet
in the the winter coat jacket and I left
it there talking talking talking I'm
talking I'm walking around I think that
oh the weather's fine I forget my coat
at the club
I walk out I go get my I go in the car I
had a rental car and I drove back to my
hotel I'm up I'm playing video games I
got a like a late morning flight and so
it's time for me to go to bed I'm like
let me pack and go to bed it's like you
know 2 30 a.m 3 A.M around that time I
realize oh I don't have my jacket I
forgot my big coat at the club but then
more importantly I'm like I can't find
my wallet
I'm I'm like oh man my wallet so I think
my wallet has got to be in this coat
right so I text a guy real late like yo
I'm so sorry I'm texting you at four
o'clock in the morning but I left my
coat at the club and I also think I left
my wallet
I gotta get on a plane I'm gonna be
stuck
he don't get back to me but now I think
let me make sure
I scour this hotel room man I'm talking
about it was a scavenger hunt man I'm
lifting up the couch taking the cushions
off the the couch I'm moving to bed I'm
looking under the thing I'm checking on
my bags and now I'm starting to panic
because the guy hasn't got back to me
okay I go down to the rental car I'm
like Oh my wallet's in the rental car go
down to the rental car I'm scouring the
rental car I look like a crazy person
it's like four o'clock in the morning
it's cold outside I'm in here looking
for like you know I'm looking underneath
the seats with the flashlight I'm like
where the hell is my wallet then I'm
thinking oh man did I have it in this
coat this one jacket and I let it drop
out because I know I have my wallet at
the club because I specifically remember
getting the check and putting it in my
wallet so now I think oh no I've done
this before where your wallet drops out
you know this particular coat I know so
I think I get in the rental car I drive
back to the club in the middle of the
night no license nothing and I'm looking
around the parking lot of the comedy
club at like 4 30 in the morning right I
drive back I'm hitting this guy up again
but I go I say Let Me Wait now I can't
sleep because I'm anxious because I'm
thinking oh man when you know when you
lose your wallet when you lose your
wallet it's more than just you lose your
wallet you're thinking about your credit
cards you're thinking about what are the
little personal items you have in there
you're thinking about personal
information you might have in there and
then for me I'm thinking about okay this
is my credit card it's a business card
that I have all of my stuff on like it's
like Hulu monthly payment Netflix a
monthly you know all the monthly
payments you have for so many things I
tip for you guys make a little file in
your iPhone Notes of all the places that
you use a particular credit card to pay
your bills with keep a list of that okay
trust me I've had it before where it was
like fraud on my credit card and then I
had to change all that stuff and it was
so helpful for me to see okay go to
Netflix go to Hulu go to Disney go to
you know T-Mobile go to you know what I
mean have all the lists
okay so I get back to the hotel it's you
know now it's five in the morning now I
can't sleep because I'm anxious thinking
about this wallet I scour the hotel room
again I'm just kind of like oh man I
don't I wait and now I'm waiting for a
reasonable time in the morning that I
could hit this guy up the the manager
owner to be like hey man I'm pretty sure
I left my jacket and my wallet at the
club he don't get back to me okay it's
like 6 30 in the morning I call him
write to voicemail it goes to voicemail
it rings and goes to voicemail
okay cut to me calling him 25 times
[Laughter]
club's thing and I go hey I think I left
my wallet somebody finally gets back to
me seven 7 45 ish a.m the guy's like
whoever it is on the other end of that
goes I'm gonna hit him up right now
I wait wait wait they go I can't get a
hold of him either so again I'm just
calling now here's where
thank goodness I'm a prepared kind of
Boy Scout in this kind of stuff I
carry my passport with me wherever I
travel I keep it in a secret pocket and
it's always there the reason why is I
always think what if I lose my license
what if I lose my wallet and I'm stuck
in a city with no way to get back
because I have no form of identification
so now I'm thinking okay I have my
passport at least I could get on this
plane and I'll have this guy
you know send me my wallet now I'm now
about the flight boards at 10 A.M okay
so the flight's about to board at 10 A.M
uh and then he calls me finally he's
like hey man you know and my first
thought is like you are definitely being
taken off my emergency contact list you
understand like I could be dead in the
ditch now you know maybe you know like
like if
I'm being kidnapped and it's like I have
my cell phone and I need to call Liam
Neeson type I think it's him you know
and I'm calling him like hey man I'm
being kidnapped help me this dude
wouldn't answer the phone for 30 calls
so he is off my emergency contact list
for sure right so he goes hey what
time's your flight like I'm like man I'm
about to board so I'm pretty sure I left
my my jacket and my wallet all right can
you just he goes you look man I'm sorry
you know what I'm going to the club in
like 30 minutes I'll let you know so I
get on my first flight it's to Chicago
so when I get to Chicago the guy texts
me back and this is the point of me
telling this story
this is why this is what he said
he goes follow along here he says
hey man good news
I found your jacket
but no wallet
what
that's good news
kidding me
you found my jacket you think that's the
good news
laughs
he thought that was the good news
that's the good news
good news
I found your jacket
but no wallet
that's not good news man
so now
I'm getting on my other flight from
Chicago to L.A and I'm just distraught
okay
because now I'm thinking
is this wallet gonna turn up
I hit up the Marriott I was staying at
and I'm like hey I think I left my
wallet in the room you know and now I'm
thinking to myself I got cash in the
wallet I'm like nobody's turning this
wallet in you know what I mean it's like
you know it's like that's it for my
wallet got the check from the club in
the wallet all this personal information
like my you know I'm like oh no and so
the flight's terrible I haven't slept
all night anxiety I get I get home I
land
I'm sitting here like oh man Rachel
picks me up and she tell she knows I'm
in a mood I haven't slept you know what
I mean we you know she has food for me
but I'm just kind of like uh she's like
it's a and she was being great you know
Rachel was being wonderful actually and
she was just like it's okay babe we can
go through your stuff and we'll you know
it's just a wallet it's okay but it's
not just the wallet it's a wallet she
gave me for a gift and I love this
wallet because it was expensive and it's
the material that it's made of it stays
fresh it just it just it's a great
wallet okay best wallet I've ever had
we get home we eat and I carry my heavy
bag upstairs all right we open the bag
Rachel says I'm going to look through
your bag to make sure she opens the bag
she grabs the first thing she grabs is I
take my vitamins with me I have like a
vitamin bag okay I have this vitamin bag
and it has my turmeric drink that I make
my uh green stuff you know I got my
multivitamins I got my uh um you know my
mushroom stuff I got all this kind of
not those kind of mushrooms but like you
know the brain mushrooms I got all kind
of stuff in my vitamin bag she grabs the
vitamin bag first opens it puts her hand
in and pulls out my wallet
ah it's just Why was it in my vitamin
bag y'all I
like I'm getting I'm going crazy she
pulls the wallet that looks at me like
here's your wallet and I'm like what she
did it so easy I feel like she went to
North Carolina snuck into my room hid my
wallet just so she could have this
moment but the feeling I had of like
Elation of relief of just being like Oh
my God my wallet and so I don't know
what happened I think
I think that I walked in the room and
like I had my vitamin bag on this little
counter I think I just threw my wallet
in the car keys towards this place you
know because I had some food and the
wallet must have went in the bag and I
didn't even think to look in the bag you
know what I mean and I know I'm pretty
sure I looked in was like uh I probably
was like I probably got the vitamin bag
and I was like it's not in the vitamin
bag that's stupid Griffin then I packed
everything but just what I went through
just the 15 hours of just stress anxiety
was
bananas
all right well
I don't know if that's entertaining but
that is what this show was about my life
My Crazy Life right My Crazy Life all
right y'all so NFL playoffs we gotta we
gotta continue to talk about the uh the
NFL playoffs
um
you know wait how come this isn't doing
this let me do this real quick there we
go NFL playoffs uh what a treat it was
like this was I was looking forward to
the NFL playoffs but this was like
really what a great weekend and I called
it too man the except for one game I
didn't get right and that was last
night's game I thought Dallas was going
to lose but they showed up against an
inferior team Tampa Bay is just not a
good team you know they were they had a
losing record and the only reason why we
even thinking about them was because of
Tom Brady and he and he looked like he
was 46 okay like Tom Brady looked like
an old man but that's fine it's fine he
had a tremendous 22-year career it's
time to move on I'm not surprised they
lost they're not a very good team they
had so many problems through the whole
year they had a losing record you know
what I mean so and then I'm looking on
this website so now it looks like the
chief so anyways so of the games that
happened this week and this is my NFL
review you if you're not into sports it
is what it is but for the people that
are I'm gonna be doing this right now
throughout the NFL playoffs because I
find it interesting I really enjoying
the NFL I like the NFL is my favorite
sport right now I still love basketball
and I love my clippers but NFL's the
best right now so okay so I called this
one
Jaguars Chargers you know while I was I
was streaming while I was out there and
I got a lot of Victories on air Griffin
gaming which you could check out on you
can check out Eric Griffin gaming on
Twitch but you can also check out Eric
Griffin gaming on YouTube as well uh and
I I've won so many games while I was it
was crazy I was on fire but anyways
well I I thought about it and I was like
you know what I think the Jaguars are
going to win because of Doug Peterson
because they have better coaching the
guys won a Super Bowl he did it with
Nick folds he did you know he did it he
knows how to get the best out of his
team he's a fantastic coach and he got
those Jags playing so they beat the
Chargers
biggest comeback third biggest comeback
in NFL history what a debacle that coach
of the Chargers they should have they
should have already cleared out his
office before the plane lands like that
dude should have got home and and and
his key card can't get into the facility
he's like yeah um security I can't my
car doesn't work I can't get inside and
they're like oh yeah yeah we need to
talk to you and they did grab them two
guys underneath his arms on either side
and they need to toss him out of the
building to his car and be like yeah
you're done thank you thank you thank
you you're done thank you right that's
how they should have done that okay but
anyways that was just a debacle they
they forced five turnovers in the first
half that hasn't been done in like so
many years and they lost the game done
okay so Jaguars are moving on and
they're about to get demolished by the
Chiefs that's my prediction for that
just the Chiefs are going they're gonna
handle business against them now Bengals
Ravens Ravens they're going through
whatever they're going through with
Lamar Jackson they should have just paid
this guy already reportedly they offered
him 130 million dollars and that's crazy
considering what they what the
guarantees that they've given out to
other quarterbacks who are not even as
good as him in my opinion but that was a
close game too divisional rivalry uh the
the the Ravens gave it their all man
they they gave it to the Bengals so
we'll see what happens with the Bengals
but it was a tough game for them but
it's a division rivalry game they know
each other they've played three times
now so I'm not surprised that it was a
good game but I still like I still think
the Bengals are the one man they they
looking real good and then again the
Dolphins uh bills division rival again
Miami had a chance to win that game I'm
I'm iffy on the bills right now man I
know Bill's Mafia is out there and all
those bills people that you guys love
the bills you know bills people they
have such support and shout out to Demar
Hamlin he seems to be doing a lot better
hopefully he gets back on the field but
anyways they didn't look good uh the
loss of uh what's the guy that got hurt
who was on the Rams
um whatever the guy I'm sure you guys
are going to tell me in the chat
so you guys will tell me that
um
I think you're starting to feel the loss
of that guy uh and I think that what do
you call it um the Dolphins
um you know I I just think the bills
they have an offensive line troubles I
think they rely on Josh Allen to do way
too much and sometimes Von Miller that's
his name thank you so much Von Miller I
they're feeling the loss of Von Miller
on defense because they can't stop
anybody so I don't know if Josh Allen is
going to be able to pull a rabbit out of
his hat every single game with his legs
with his arm with his decision making he
got sacked seven times I I'm picking
right now I think the Bengals are gonna
beat the bills and they're going to go
on to play the Chiefs and that's the
that's going to be a rematch of last
year so
uh so we'll see what's going on with
that so I think that that's going to be
a great matchup but that Miami shout out
to them hopefully Tua can come back
right hopefully tuna can come back but
if not they need to find a quarterback
and maybe it's time for Aaron Rodgers to
come to leave Green Bay if I was Miami I
would try to get Aaron Rodgers you know
because you know Aaron Rodgers can you
imagine can you imagine Aaron Rodgers
with those receivers
oh way so we'll see what happens there
now in the NFC as I said last night
Dallas put the whoop on an inferior team
like Dallas was just a better team top
to bottom than Tampa Bay we'll see if
that can carry on to uh the next round I
don't know I'm not sure who plays who
now like I think
um I think New York plays the to plays
Philly I'm I'm not sure I think no no no
no
Philadelphia Eagles end up playing uh oh
yeah yeah yeah that's what it is New
York plays Philly New York you know
let's get to that game too so
um the Giants I picked the Giants to
beat the Vikings I think a lot of people
picked that but not only did they beat
the Vikings but Danny dimes dude Daniel
Jones looked good I think he played his
way into a good contract and let me tell
you something about New York they're not
going to pay him 48 million dollars a
year whatever the the high market value
is for quarterbacks they gonna pay
Daniel Jones like 40. maybe even 37
something like that and that's going to
be a team friendly deal and they're
going to be good for like the next five
years because they got they got a couple
of draft picks they got saquon Barkley
like the giants look good man so look
out for the Giants so Giants Eagles
you know this is the first time the
Giants have been in the playoffs in a
while and this is the first time this is
the first time for Jalen Hurst as the
quarterback we don't know if he's 100 so
that might be an upset in the making you
know Giants you know they got a history
we'll see that Giant Eagles game is
going to be that bomb okay
um and then on the other side we got uh
the 49ers who looked dominant as hell
man they looked dominant dude and Brock
Purdy Brock Purdy looked like a rookie
he didn't play well and the dude still
had like four touchdowns in over 300
yards so he was making some rookie
mistakes but that team is stacked from
top to bottom to me that's the best team
in the NFC if not the league is the San
Francisco 49ers and the only thing the
asterisks on them is this is the last
pick in the draft rookie quarterback No
rookie has ever won the Super Bowl so
we'll see how that goes okay and then
now they play the Dallas Cowboys so
that's going to be the game so you got
Cowboys Nations these people have been
supporting the Cowboys for 25 years I
think the Cowboys have already done
enough to be like all right you guys are
a good team now let's let's build on
this I need another receiver or
something like that so I'm not going to
be surprised if San Francisco wins this
game I think they should win the game
actually I think San Francisco is better
than Dallas but at the same time who
knows is this the magic Dallas finally
did it they got over the hump it's a
hard pick but I'm picking the 49ers in
that game all right uh and I'm picking
the Chiefs over the Jags and I'm picking
Bengals over the bills so that's uh how
I feel about
that's how I feel about that guys
That's How Daddy feels about that so
there you go
how come this doesn't this is supposed
to this is supposed to change the
background and it's not doing it I don't
I don't know what the hell is going on
here I have to like do like this real
quick I gotta switch out of it boom and
go here boom there it is I don't know
why it does that that's really weird so
oh if I go to my screen capture so this
oh I have a screen let's go to screen
capture here so yeah this one website uh
SB Nation they were like ranking the
teams that have the eight remaining NFL
playoff teams ranked by likelihood of
winning it all so they got the Chiefs
number one good pick I think I think the
Chiefs are just solid they got Patrick
at Holmes probably gonna be the MVP
Philadelphia Eagles uh I don't know
I don't know if I uh agree with that I
think I I would switch Eagles and 49ers
on this one uh 49ers or the third chance
uh Eagles second to third then they got
Buffalo fourth Cincinnati five I would
switch that to I don't agree with this
list then they have Dallas six I can
agree and uh Jacksonville seven and
Giants eighth Giants yeah I can agree
with that I can agree with that
assessment from that website so we'll
see what's going on with that so anyways
that's all that's my Sports Talk segment
of this episode
um okay also I want to say something I
got an email oh let me find the email
you know what I should actually find the
email oh
um I'm gonna talk about this email after
I do let's let's take care of some
business right now we have to take care
of some business uh I want to talk about
diet smoke y'all diet smoke uh diet
smoke uh they make federally legal
premium THC products
um
so I want to take a break right now and
talk about my new favorite sponsor once
again diet smoke
uh they guarantee that there's th they
get diet smokes variety of guarantees
their THC product for everyone and we're
not just talking about flavor or variety
either the guy Blends from melatonin for
sleep they got blends with caffeine uh
from when you're on the move if you need
an elevated Vibe they have so many
different options they sent me some
stuff and like I'm not a smoker you know
I'm not a smoker I don't drink and
whatever like that but you know in the
last couple years I've I've tried a
little you know uh THC with just a
um I'm sorry like uh CBD with a little
bit of stuff and so like if you need a
little something to like to be calm to
help you go to sleep to just help you
chill out just get a Vibe I I do
recommend diet smoke you know uh most
importantly diet smoke is great for all
levels of THC consumers like myself
experienced users or the Delta high for
when they can't melt into their couch
and still want to function you know what
I mean like that's such a great little
line right there for that uh just named
diet smokes U.S weekly is just named
diet smokes Delta a gummies as the best
for beginners I'm a beginner and if
you're a beginner and you're worried
about I don't want to be all high I
highly recommend diet smoke Dyke smoke
cares about their customers on top of
guaranteed quality through available lab
tests they consistently release new
flavors to keep the experience fresh
each flavor is hand-picked through
several weeks of testing and sampling
before released best of all if you don't
enjoy your experience their friendly
customer service team will quickly
address the issue for Reverend mcgriffin
listeners shop now at dietsmoke.com and
use code Griffin for 20 off your entire
first order that's a great deal y'all if
you want like I say if you're a beginner
try this out that's dietsmoke.com
codegriffin at checkout for 20 off
okay
uh let me see if I can find this email
so I got an email and you know what if
you guys want to email me you can email
me at Eric griffin.com
um
I I do like getting emails from people
you know what I mean and so this guy
sent me an email
um I I thought I had it I thought I had
it ready to go and this is so funny
because this is actually what this email
is about I wish I could find it
um because the guy was like hey man you
know I listened to the podcast and you
know when you say it is what it is when
you don't know stuff you know he's just
kind of kind of getting on me for like
not remembering names and all this kind
of stuff and I wish I could find it see
I'm not prepared
this exactly what you guys talking about
but listen dude I appreciate you
emailing and I know you want me to get
names right and get stuff right but I
just want you to also remember that I am
doing this live I'm doing it live
because I like just being fresh off the
cuff from my head you get an honest
assessment you know I'm not like
bullshitting I'm just out here talking
about stuff I think that's the appeal of
my show I would hope so when I have
guests for sure I like to think that I'm
way more prepared when I have a guest or
if I'm pre-recording something for
whatever reason but you do have to
remember that I am doing this live so
sometimes I'm coming up with things like
this and I'm like oh yeah what was that
guy's name and then I just you know I'm
50 man I don't remember everything
that's going on you know I don't
remember I don't remember everything
that's going on so sometimes I need a
little refresher and I like to go to the
chat and be like yo chat what was the
name of this or that and you guys are
really good about uh helping me uh you
know remember stuff you'll be like oh
Eric you're talking about this and I
appreciate that so but I hear you man I
appreciate you and I will keep that in
mind okay
all right so let's talk about this
um I was on the plane so now this is the
reviews
um spoiler alert you know what I mean
uh I don't know I'm not actually going
to give necessarily any spoilers I don't
think but this this is such an old movie
that it doesn't matter so when I'm
traveling again so I'm on a plane and
sometimes I look at a movie on the plane
and be like oh wow either it's such a
terrible movie that I do with one of my
movie Recaps or it's such a weird movie
I do one of my movie Recaps and
sometimes I'll watch a movie and be like
this actually was a pretty great movie
and so and shout out to my buddy Kevin
Eaton who was one of the original
producers of Workaholics he was a
co-writer of this movie so first up this
movie I want to talk about uh screen cap
let's go to my screens thing is this
Nicholas Cage movie called The
unbearable weight of massive Talent the
unbearable weight of massive talent and
you know it's an action-packed comedy
Nicholas Cage plays Nicholas Cage
channeling his iconic character as he's
caught between a Super Fan played by
Pedro Pascal and the CI agent played by
my girl Tiffany haddish okay so I just
want to say you know what I really
really enjoyed this movie you know it's
like Nicholas Cage is getting a lot of
you know he gets a lot of slack because
he's in a lot of like really bad movies
you know he and he does all kind of
movies dude he'll be a wizard all of a
sudden he's a wizard now he's even gonna
be Dracula coming out in this movie
called Renfield like he's always in some
like out-of-pocket movies where you're
just like I wonder why Nicholas Cage did
that and then like the rumor is like
he's got a big tax bill and he has a bad
spending habits so and and so that's why
he does any movie right
but um this one so he's playing himself
and these issues that I'm talking about
he's making fun of himself in this movie
so immediately I enjoyed that I just
enjoyed him like being a character of
himself like he's being this character
that we think he is right so it gives it
a little bit of authenticity because
it's Nicolas Cage and he's kind of like
yeah let's make fun of me so
automatically I'm in I I it made him
more endearing you know it just made him
be like I really like Nicholas Cage like
the real Nicholas Cage uh and so
um you know so he plays Nicholas Cage
and then like this guy played by uh
what's his name
um paid like I said already Pedro Pascal
who is it that dude is a fantastic actor
I love Pedro Pascal he's a really good
actor okay so he's playing this like
arms dealer or you think he's I won't
even give away what happens he's like I
know he's supposedly this Super Fan
nigga's cage needs money he's got this
weird relationship with his daughter his
daughter's kind of like wow you're so
self-absorbed and you know he's like you
what you would think a superstar guy
like that makes everything about him
right and so he's got these marital
issues and his daughter and so he needs
the money so he's getting paid a million
dollars to go just be Nicholas Cage and
hang out with this guy right million
dollars if somebody said I want to hang
out with Montez here's a million dollars
bro purple shirt purple tie I'm on the
way to wherever I need to go okay so he
gets on the private jet he goes and
talks to the guy and they build up a
sort of friendship but they're actually
both really good actors so I believed
everything that was happening like
there's this great scene in the movie
where spoiler alert
it doesn't matter it's not that batch of
a spoiler I'm just saying that in case
but they both take like mushrooms or LSD
or something and they're having this
moment with each other right and it was
such a real genuine
funny ass moment that I was just
cackling on this plane but it just I
really enjoyed the movie I enjoyed the
story I enjoyed like from beginning to
end I thought it was super entertaining
so I highly I highly recommend this
movie and again shout out to my boy
Kevin Eaton he was one of the co-writers
of the movie him and a guy named Tom
gormicken I don't know who that is but I
do know Kevin so shout out to them for
that that was a fantastic uh it was a
fantastic movie and I gave it like eight
woo-woos
[Music]
foreign
so that was a good one
this made me think of something right
now that I forgot you know what I forgot
to talk about
I forgot to talk about my thoughts on
why they canceled the Workaholics movie
Man
so Paramount Plus
it meets with the boys and they're like
yeah Workaholics doesn't fit in to our
Global strategy what
your Global strategy really
uh I I I I don't understand
um you know I I don't understand it okay
like they're saying that Workaholics
doesn't fit into their Global what's
their Global strategy is uh is it
entertainment like they don't want to
make the Workaholics movie but they want
to make this
Zoe 101 sequel movie starring Jamie Lynn
Spears ordered at Paramount plus what
hey shout out to Jamie Lynn and good for
you guys but if Workaholics tell me how
this is their Global strategy
you know
Global strategy my [__] man that's my
[__] has more Global strategy than
Zoe 101 over the Workaholics movie now
I'ma tell you I'm gonna tell you my raw
unfiltered thoughts about why they not
making the Workaholics movie and I could
be completely wrong and maybe somebody
at Paramount will reach out and be like
well Eric that's just not correct this
is not why we're not making this move
right okay
let me tell you why I think they're not
making a movie
because it's three
straight white guys starring in the
movie who are being silly and they drink
and they take weed and mushrooms and the
stories are just three sort of like
weird College sort of guys who knows now
what they would be in the movie just you
know being goof offs and just being fun
and funny
this ain't there so I think that
everybody's so freaking woke and worried
about this small Fringe group on Twitter
where there's no engagement on Twitter
no one even cares about that stupid app
anymore and I think that they're just
kind of like do we want to make a movie
with straight white guys as if straight
white guys aren't a thing anymore like
yo just can we have some Artistic
integrity and just make good
products can we just make good content
without worrying about pleasing a fringe
group how about make both how about make
a great Workaholics that inspired a
generation of people to get through
college and and all the people who are
now 35 41 right now 45 they got kids and
they remember oh man I used to love
Workaholics the like did were they like
oh I used to love the white show that's
not what they were saying oh I used to
love that Stoner no they just just loved
the relationship that these three guys
portrayed in this show and they're still
doing it they're real friends these are
three real friends who are still friends
today and they have a great podcast out
there too that they haven't had me on
the bastards but the point is
that it translated to the screen that's
why the show was great people loved it
people loved the Workaholics they still
love it today so for Paramount plus to
act like this is not a part of their
Global strategy I call [__] okay at
some point one of these companies are
gonna have to get their head out of
their ass and just make good content if
you want to worry about inclusion and
diversity and all this stuff it doesn't
necessarily have to start with the
finished product how about start in the
development phase let's get more women
in directing and writing and on set and
but if you're making a show about three
straight white guys that should be okay
okay nobody thinks you're racist or out
of out of pocket if you do take your
head out of your ass and start just
looking at things you don't have to look
at everything through the prism of
social justice and all this stuff you
know yes there are things out there that
need to change that we need to work on
as a society but it's not Workaholics
okay it's not Workaholics so
that pissed me off
so we'll see what happens they're
shopping at other places so keep you
keep a look out and maybe you'll see the
Workaholics gang back together again I
hope so
rant over
okay the last thing I want to talk about
is this new show I've been watching on
AMC plus kind of like AMC plus man uh
I'm a fan of Anne Rice and rice the
writer I I I read a lot of her books The
Vampire Lestat an interview with a
vampire I like I love all the Queen of
the Damned and they've made movies about
those those books and they've now
they're making shows there's a remake of
The Interview with a Vampire and it's a
great remake and this is an example of
what I'm talking about with Artistic
integrity they actually made a really
great show they Diversified it in a
meeting that they they put some
diversity in it and they changed some
characters but the way they did it it's
really great so I enjoy the acting I
enjoy the story I enjoy that show and
and I when I look at it I I try not to
think about like you know how you see
like a commercial and you're like well
another mixed couples renting a car at
Avis you know how you feel that energy
Interview with a Vampire I'm gonna be
honest you felt it at first because
you're like oh look at this but the way
they dealt with it within the show I
thought was
tremendous so now cut to there's a show
called Mayfair witches starring
Alexandria uh Daddario I think that's
how you say her name I love this chick
celebrity my celebrity crush because she
just I just I just she just got this
weird look you know what I'm saying she
got just wait let me get to um where's
the screen cap she got this weird look
you know it's that chick with the like
you know she got all she got she's got
these haunting blue eyes like she never
has to like really get any makeup when
she's playing like weird characters but
Mayfair witches are really really like
it didn't get the highest IMDb rating
but it's got It's really popular amongst
people uh it follows a neurosurgeon who
discovers she's the unlikely heir to a
family of witches she must contend with
the Sinister presence that has haunted
her family for Generations that's a
basic thing about the show but
um yeah so
um I have AMC Plus or you can get AMC I
think it's I always think of these apps
and stations now is just like I just
think of them like I think a Netflix or
HBO so AMC plus is just like that so you
can see the stuff early but if you have
AMC in your cable or YouTube TV or
whatever it is you can watch it every
Sunday but if you have AMC plus you get
to stream and whatever like that I could
take it live to places
um
yeah
I like this show you know
um it's it like she's she's a great
actress like she was on What's that show
on
um um
HBO about the hotel see this is an
example of what I'm talking about when I
when the guy's like hey man be prepared
well I didn't know I was going to talk
about this White Lotus I remembered [__]
you so White Lotus she's great on that
the first season of White Lotus and
she's really great in this so you're
following her you're going through her
experiences and it's just like I like
but y'all know if you know me if you
watch my podcast a lot you know I like
witchy dragony I like Harry Potter and I
like all that kind of stuff you know so
this is an example of a great a great
show about that stuff and uh and rice is
a great writer in that Supernatural
world so this is a I highly recommend
this show I don't give it eight woo-woos
but
she's doing a good job
there's only two episodes out right now
I watched both episodes and so there's
kind of setting up the world to kind of
letting you know this is where we're
going with it this is what it's about I
got all this backstory so a lot of times
that kind of stuff can be real slow but
I think she's doing a good enough job
that
you kind of feel for her you kind of
follow along about what she's doing so I
give uh I give this show probably like I
don't know six and a half seven woo-woos
[Music]
Bobo
there's the woo-woos for that so yeah so
make sure you check out
um Alexandria Daddario in this movie and
um and and somebody hit me up about book
club I guess I am doing riffing with
Griffin book club so I want you guys to
check out if you're a reader and you
like fantasy and science fiction I want
you to check out this guy his name is
Christopher G Nuttall Christopher G
Nuttall this guy's a prolific writer I
talk about him all the time and I'm
going to continue to talk about him he's
got a series called schooled in Magic I
want if you're into like fantasy I love
the audiobooks but if you're into
fantasy sci-fi drag Dungeons and Dragons
type of stuff check this story out
schooled in Magic it's about this girl
named Emily who lives in our world and
uh a evil wizard makes a deal with a
demon and pulls her out of our world
into this Medieval Times world and it's
about her and it's there's 20 books in
this series plus spin-off books it's
great the dude is really prolific writer
I love Christopher G Nuttall so make
sure you check out that series and if
you do hit me up about it so you can
know so anyways guys
um
that's gonna be it for this episode of
roofing with Griffin uh let me get my
music queued up for the rap recap
because you know how we do it you know
how we do it
yeah I got some songs I don't remember
where who even all sent me some of these
songs in the past but I want to pick a
new one that I haven't that I probably
haven't played in a while you know what
I mean I don't remember this one but
anyways guys thanks for watching the
show yeah
thanks for watching with Griffin
it's the rap recap
put your fist up against that
I got a lot to talk about this was a
beautiful show
I appreciate all the shout outs let's
get that beat and let's go
[Music]
coaching like Lane kissing
if I took tobacco I'd be dipping
yeah what was
[Music]
all the rage
make a bunch of bad movies
he need a smoothie
saw a nice one
that one was the one
so check it out
and then give a shout out
Shout
they know you want the clout
oh Mayfair witches I love all them
that's how we do it and you knew it
NFL is weak
and is Sleek
Eric Griffin Chic
it's not weak I'm just kidding
the NFL is great for goodness sake
that's all it takes
49ers cheeks
[Music]
the workaholic movie
they did this movie
so we could be the best damn movie that
we can't be
Paramount plus you
you [__] I don't give up
we gonna go someplace else
you'll see
be a hit
the [__]
whoa y'all that's it
every perfect gaming is the best I've
arrested
[Music]
see you next week and I'll be back never
whack
[Music]
like like sweet Slack
dad raps coming at you once again y'all
I'll see you next week
and I am gonna start watching Last of Us
so just check that out too but see y'all
thanks for watching riffing with Griffin
[Music]